[Music]
hello YouTube just lovers in my friends
this is guns in here welcome to my
second episode of love in Tulsa
cylindric Ruta from the black
perspective in this episode I'm going to
cover all the side lines before we
reached to the starting point of the
Leventhal Sicilian main line as you know
from the first part and the intro the
opening arises as follows efore c5
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and in the
cities we are only looking at the open
Sicilian ruruta which start with d4 and
after C captors d4 Knight captures d4
black plays this time attic thrust in
the center
Aoife now if white has to keep his
slight advantage then he has to play
Knight to be Phi however it is very
common for white players to churn out
other Knight moves and specially in
below 2002 now in practice these are
some of the obvious choices so let's see
each by turn why these three are the
knight moves are bad and how black get
advantage out of it the first move I
want to consider is Knight to b3 after
that the simple thing you have to
remember against all this other Knight
moves the first move of the black is
very common Knight to f6 attacking on
the weak efore pawn obviously the
mainline start with Knight to c3 however
before we look at it there are two
golden rules you have to remember at
this point number one if you open in
place either the move f3 or Bishop to d3
then you are going to play the moon d5
and in this opening
whenever black can manage to play defy
without any sort of counter tactics then
he is instantly better in almost all the
variations number two if you opponent
continue with Bishop to g5 then you
always hit this bishop with at six and
get the bishop pair let me show you what
I mean let's say white continue with f3
then you play the moon defy and after he
captures defy and the Moon Knight
captures defy at this point not only
black is ahead in peace development and
he has a wonderful Center but white has
weakened himself by playing the MU f3
and that's why position already looks
quite good for the black camp well same
goes for the move Bishop to g5 as after
this move we are going to continue with
at 6 and white has to take denied as he
cannot play the move Bishop to edge for
the simple reason is after G Phi Bishop
to g3 and the move Knight captures a
fool suddenly just on the 8th move black
come up with an extra pawn the important
point you should know that after Queen
to defy black is not losing upon as
Knight to f6 first hitting the Queen and
then we are going to consolidate our
extra pawn so obviously at this point or
what has to take the knight but after
that we can simply recapture with our
Queen and the important point about this
position is not only black get the
bishop pair but in the long run white
cannot stop avert ematic defy break for
example a sample line can draw like this
Knight to c3 looking at juicy d5 square
so that's why we have to pin down the
snide and White has to support it
otherwise we are going to fracture white
pawn structure
Queen to d3 what else
and now very simple idea by black first
he likes to castle and after a three we
can take this Knight Queen captures d3
is obvious response now we will play d6
and the point is no matter however white
responds let's say in one game
white continue with Quinn to g3 black
plays Bishop to e6 and now after rook to
d1 and the move rook to d8 it is pretty
clear that black achieve his traumatic
break defy and get a very good game out
of it
so considering all these factors at this
point white has to play Knight to c3 and
this is what I like about this line
every single move from the black is a
very forcing burn it just like Black is
controlling the game from the starting
point the obvious move you have to
remember is Bishop to b4 pinning down
the night thus threatening the Moon
Knight captures evil and accordingly
White has two choices if Bishop to g5
then this time around my recommendation
is you should first capture on c3 and
after pawn capture c3 you can see that
we have given wide a horrible pawn
structure on the Queen side and on top
we are going to get the bishop pair back
with at 6 as we have seen earlier Bishop
to h4 drops the pawn so white has to
play Bishop captures f6
but after Queen captures f6 it is very
obvious that black is in a completely
driving seat ok let's look at what
happens after Bishop to d3 and if you
remember of a foster golden rule yup
it's very obvious defy
achieving this center break and after he
kept his defy and nightcaps is defy
black threats are already looming on the
a to move the game bishop to d2
what else and now the simple choice
nightcap to c3
if pawn capture c3 then Bishop to b6 and
even though let's say if I take with the
bishop it doesn't matter because we are
going to take this bishop and after
Castle the thematic fracture porn gives
black a healthy advantage the second
move I want to consider is Knight to a5
which is a rare guest in this variation
as it allowed what black wants to do
namely defy and create a problem in the
white camp here it doesn't matter
whether white continued it he captures
defy or Queen captures defy in both the
scenario black get a very easy to play
and a comfortable game let me show you
one of the game in the database which
highlight the problem in the white camp
Queen kept us defy happen in the game
black simply exchange the Queen and then
take on f5 which forces Y to capture the
piece back with D capture c6 and now
very simple point have to c6 yes indeed
black has to isolated pawn but look at
the development and very important thing
black has a center which gives him ample
opportunity to attack undeveloped right
side c3 happening the game and now very
simple plan black pieces goes to the
very natural square Knight to f6 Bishop
to e2 Bishop to c5 castle on the Kings
side castle on the Queen side and now
Bishop to g5
which I think it's a kind of inaccuracy
as after at six who I thought that he's
giving black some horrible pawn
structures but now the problem comes
into the surface as beaver Knight
doesn't have good squares in the game
why tried night to e3 but after just one
move rook to d2 black obtained are
completely winning advantage why try to
bail out with Bishop check but after
King c7 and the move Knight to c4 which
at first sight
save all the thread but rook to c2 and
the threat is very obvious Bishop to d3
and removing the knight white find
nothing better then try to exchange the
rook with rook to c1 but here he has to
face this deadly tactics did you spot it
yup it's very obvious Bishop captures f2
winning a very important pawn white find
nothing better than king h1 but after
rook takes rook takes and the move
Bishop to d3 with the bishop pair and a
healthy pawn advantage black indeed win
the game in few moves white can try over
here II kept his d5 but that doesn't
change the story as after the simple
continuation Bishop captures a fire pawn
captures a6 queen capture Stephen King
capture Stephen now tempo mu castle on
the Queen side Bishop to d2 and simple
recapture of the pawn we have the same
scenario except white has misplaced King
on the D 1 square
the third obvious choice by the white is
to play Knight to f3 which is in fact
the second most popular choice by white
however our response is very
straightforward yup Knight to f6
pressurizing e4 and after Knight to c3
the second obvious choice I think you
got it right Bishop to b4 pinning down
the night thus threatening the e4 pawn
well routine moves comes to the same
conclusion
so if Bishop to d3 then we have defy if
Bishop to g5 then we have at 6 and black
has no problem at all so accordingly
two other active moves has been tried by
the white amongst them the first move I
want to consider is Bishop to D 2 which
is unpinning the night
however after simple capture on c3 and
Bishop capture c3 yes indeed both the
points are hanging but black is the
first one who is going to take it and
White has to be very careful here as
there is a small trap guys if white
continues wait Bishop captures ePHI
which is a big time blunder as after
simple Knight captures defy night
capture c5 and the move Queen check
black get a piece and in fact the game
so obviously White has to avoid that
variation and the correct response is
Knight captures ePHI but the amazing
part is still white get losing position
after the following forcing sequence
night cap to c3 White has to take on c6
and now we will get rid of our isolated
pawn with D capture c6 Queen captures
Queen King takes and be cap to c3 the
same crippled pawn are emerging again in
again which black loves to play against
it
the second active move I can try over
here is Bishop to c4
the idea is black can't even touch on e4
as after Bishop captures f7 or the move
Queen to defy White literally enjoys the
attacking position so obviously we are
not going to be that greedy and here I'm
going to suggest one of the modern move
which has been hardly even played and
that is Knight to a5 attacking the
bishop White has two choices if he
become greedy and continue with Knight
captures ePHI then the simplest sequence
goes as follows
Knight capture Sifu night-cap to c4 and
now Knight captures efore which gives
black a very good game probably the
highest Lee played more in this position
is Bishop to defy but I don't think so
it's a nice choice as after the
following continuation Bishop capture c3
pawn captures c3 Queen to c7 attacking
the pawn and in the database one of the
game continue with Bishop to b2 which
already looks so pathetic and against
this black simply responds with Knight
captures defy Queen captures defy and
the MU D sings well I thought that this
is not possible due to the simple rook
to d1 and this exponent is going to lost
but black defended elegantly with castle
on the Kings side if white doesn't
capture on d6 then next move is Bishop
to b6 so let's see what happens after
Queen captures d6 which is obviously a
bad choice and I know that you have seen
instantly right yup it's Queen captures
d6 rook captures d6 and now the winning
shot
like to see far stamping the domination
so by looking at all these variations we
come to conclusion that if white doesn't
want to get a bad position in the
opening then he has to play Knight to be
fine okay
I hope you've seen the intro and you
know your opening choices here you have
to play a six attacking the knight and
the main move is Knight to d6 but let's
look at the last two side line moves by
white what happens if he goes back well
the first move is very bad as after
Knight to a three we can continue with
our thematic pattern Knight to f6
attacking on e4 we already know what to
do if white plays any other moves then
Knight to c3 but the beauty about this
position is even Knight to c3 is not
possible at this point the simple reason
is Black has this winning win the
picture b5 and you can already see
before is a big time threat and unlike
reznikov variation where white has
already played the move Bishop to g5
pinning down this f6 Knight in this line
our Knight is free to go anywhere Knight
to d5 is the only logical response here
but that leads to the loss of a pawn on
just eight more of the game and you
can't ask better opening advantage than
this
the final move I want to consider is
night back to c3 if you see these arrows
you will understand how pathetic white
plays so this knight on c3 take four
moves to reach to that square and the
important thing is the knight on b1 is
not a happy chappy as he has to go now
to the inferior square well no matter
black plan is very obvious you are going
to continue eight Knight to f6 and once
again it doesn't matter whether your
opponent continued with Bishop to d3
Bishop to c4 Bishop to g5 our plan will
remain same to illustrate how easy this
position is for the black I like to show
you a model game between two masters
where white continue with Bishop to g5
pinning down the night thus threatening
Knight to d5 but black played equally
elegantly with Bishop to c5 completely
stopping Knight to d5
why what happens after Knight to d5 well
very obvious you can see the tactical
idea where black yup this
boomba move Bishop captures f2 if King
to e2 then Bishop goes back to c5 and a
black is a clear pawn up and other
option King captures f2 is even worse as
after Knight captures efore and black
emerged with a two-point advantage by
getting his piece back so obviously
Knight to d5 is a vast choice for the
void and accordingly he should
concentrate on developing f1 Bishop now
the good point is it doesn't matter
whether your opponent continued with
Bishop to d3 or Bishop to c5 black
planning of campaign will remain same so
for example in this game white continue
with Bishop to b3
black plays at 6:00 and now if you take
the night then black will obtain the
bishop pair so naturally white continue
with Bishop to h4 but after that black
continue with the obvious move d6 if
Knight to d5 then GFI is a very strong
reply and same goes for night 2 d2 as
Bishop to e6 creates the defy push so at
this position most of a new player is
castle on the Kings side which looks so
natural but the amazing part is it is a
big time error by white camp
well now you will see the aggressive
side of the love and tall Sicilian as
the target is set down which black
immediately jump on it with GFI
attacking the bishop bishop to g3 and
now no prize for guessing next reply
very obvious yup you guessed it
h5 so it is pretty clear that black is
going for the throat if h4 then Knight
to g5 is extremely strong so in the game
white continue with h3 but it doesn't
stop black at all as after h4 pressure
up to h2 and the move G for black attack
is crashing through on the Kings side
yet captures g4 happen Bishop captures
g4 comes out with the tempo Bishop to e2
defending and now the obvious move rook
to g8 lining up the rook against
tweaking White King get out of the open
file and black continues assault with h3
white desperately blocked thing with g3
but by doing so virtually he is a piece
down now black pick up the pace with a
fourth gear Bishop captures e2 Queen
captures e2 and the Moon Knight to d4
attacking the Queen Queen goes back to
even and now very nice move Queen to b6
attacking 1 b2 so every move is creating
a thread and black is playing much more
active game Knight to a4 happen on the
ball white thinks that he can get rid of
this pesky Bishop but after Queen to c6
black is attacking to spot night to see
if I happen pon capture c5 and now
indeed there is a threat of capturing on
e4 so I thought that okay I can defend
all the threads with f3
but then he get this rude shock can you
guessed it yup it's a nasty boom-boom
might get c4 white can't even touch this
night so in the game he played Queen to
even only to get double surprise Knight
captures f3 what a game
black literally on the white at this
position the game doesn't last long as
white continue with rook captures f3 but
after Knight captures g3 obviously you
cannot take with the bishop as Queen
captures f3 leads to disaster to the
white camp so in the game white continue
with Queen captures g3 but after rook
captures g3 in the view of white rook
Hanks white plays Knight to d2 and just
resign the game as he can easily see
that after rook captures f3 surprisingly
enough the game will be checkmated in
three moose
that's it guys I hope I have given
enough information to play this
variation very confidently if you open
and played any sideline moves and all
you have to remember is this golden move
that once the knight moves then you have
to play Knight to f6 attacking on e4 and
look out for this the mattock thrust
defy which already gives a comfortable
and easy to play position for the black
camp well thank you for watching this
video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I'll meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care